ja willkommen zur heutigen Sendung heute
geht es um das Thema
wissenschaftstransfer vielleicht auch
noch allgemeiner formuliert
Wissenstransfer das soll jetzt eine
Einführung in dieses Thema sein das ist
ein sehr wichtiges Thema weil die
Wissenschaft sei die Geisteswissenschaft
sei die Naturwissenschaft heutzutage
immer weniger im Elfenbeinturm verhartt
sondern es große Anstrengung gibt die
Erkenntnisse die aktuellen Forschungen
auch an ein größeres Publikum mitunter
auch nicht wissenschaftlich sein kann zu
kommunizieren im Folgenden geht es vor
allem um den Geist des
wissenschaftlichen
wissenschaftstransfer oder
Wissenstransfer also
Geisteswissenschaften
Kulturwissenschaften fass ich alle
darunter Philosophie
Theologie alle möglichen anderen
Philosophien die jetzt nicht
Wissenschaften die jetzt nicht auf
Experimente angewiesen sind die nicht so
sehr Naturwissenschaft en sind sondern
die sich mit kulturellen sprachlichen
historischen Phänomenen befassen das ist
so der Fokus der heutigen Themensendung
und ich sag etwas zum Programm wir
werden uns erst mal überlegen was
überhaupt wissenschaftstransfer ist und
wie er funktioniert worin er vielleicht
auch scheitern kann was die Gefahren
dieses Transfers sind wir werden dann
wissenschaftstransfer und
Wissenschaftskommunikation unter dem
Gesichtspunkt der Medialität des
Medieneinsatzes betrachten und dann
konkrete Praxis und Anwendungsbeispiele
anhand von konkreten Medien geben diese
Medien können traditionelle Medien sein
wie etwa Bücher sie können aber auch
neue Medien sein wie z.B
Internetblogs oder Podcasts oder Youtube
Videos darauf kommen wir dann noch
genauer zu sprechen und ich werde auch
zeigen worin die Vorteile und die
Nachteile der jeweiligen Medien liegen
jetzt kann man sich fragen worin liegt
überhaupt die Besonderheit von
wissenschaftstransfer ganz allgemein
kann man sagen dass
wissenschaftstransfer die Kommunikation
zwischen Wissenschaft auf der einen
Seite und einer Öffentlichkeit ist die
kann wissenschaftlich sein die kann ein
anderen fachkultur Z gehören das kann
auch dieselbe fachkultur sein
Historikerin können an
Historiker interessante
Forschungsergebnisse kommunizieren z.B
auf fachagungen es besteht aber auch die
Möglichkeit z.B in theologischen
Kontexten einen breiteres Publikum
Erkenntnisse der Wissenschaft zu
kommunizieren das muss nicht unbedingt
wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse sein es
können auch andere Information sein also
wir haben ja mehrere Möglichkeiten
Wissenschaft wissenschaftliche
Öffentlichkeit oder die Wissenschaft in
Richtung Öffentlichkeit eine noch
breitere
Öffentlichkeit die vielleicht
außerwissenschaftlich bezeichnet werden
kann ganz wichtig ist jetzt hier dass
gelingende Wissenschaftskommunikation
wie überhaupt jede Form von
Kommunikation immer den geeigneten
Einsatz von Medien voraussetzt was
bedeutet es wir müssen schauen was ist
unser Publikum oder was soll unser
Publikum sein welche Alterstruktur hat
dieses Publikum welch Wissenshintergrund
wel Informationsstand welche Interessen
hat dieses Publikum und danach sollten
wir dann auch unsere Medien wählen nicht
nur die Inhalte die wir vermitteln
wollen sondern auch die Medien müssen
angemessen sein dem Inhalt den wir
vermitteln wollen und der ist ja
wiederum abhängig von der Öffentlichkeit
wir müssen es also abstimmen ähm an das
Publikum mögliche Medien sind wie gesagt
Monographien wir kommen darauf noch
genauer zu sprechen Sammelbände
zeitschrifte Aufsätze Blogs Newsletter
Wikis Open Access Publikation und es
gibt noch viele mehr wir gehen darauf
genauer noch gleich ein davor möchte ich
jedch die Frage thematisieren was
überhaupt ein Medium ist der Begriff
wird häufig sehr schwammig gebraucht
ganz allgemein kann man sagen dass
Medien zwischen Sender und Empfänger
vermitteln sie vermitteln Information
Gehalte mentale Gehalte vermitteln sie
die können verschiedene Formen
phänomenologisch haben das können
akustische Gehalte sein die natürlich
immer semantische Gehalte transportieren
zuum meist es gibt natürlich auch
Musikmedien die keine semantischen also
bedeutungsvollen kognitiv bedeutsamen
sprachlich verfasst Gehalte
kommunizieren wie z.B Musik Musik hat
vielleicht auch eine Bedeutung die jetzt
aber vielleicht nicht sprachlich
kommuniziert ist wenn es nicht gerade
Gesang ist ja als man kann verschiedene
Dinge kommunizieren dabei verschiedene
Kanäle ansprechen akustisch das Ohr
visuell wenn es Bilder sind die
kommuniziert werden oder eben auch Texte
die stärker kognitiv verfasst sind
Medien vermitteln Information welche Art
auch immer diese Information jetzt ist
sein
mag wichtig ist jetzt an dieser Stelle
zu betonen dass Medien nicht nur
Information vermitteln das ist ein sehr
einseitiger Medienbegriff wir eben
häufig verstanden wird sondern Medien
verändern die Information auch die sie
vermitteln sie enthalten
Selbstinformation sie tragen selbst noch
mal was dazu es ist nicht so dass die
Medien den vermittelten oder zu
vermittelnden information äußerlich sind
wieo ein Transportbehälter der irgendwie
eine Nahrung zu etwas anderem
transportiert die Nahrung dabei aber
unangetastet lässt sondern die Wahl des
Mediums ist auch entscheidend für die
Art der Information die übertragen wird
hier gibt's einen kanadischen
Kulturwissenschaftler Marshall mcluhen
von 1911 bis 1980 hatte gelebt und der
hat eine berühmte Aussage getätigt
nämlich the medium is the message das
Medium ist die Botschaft oder die
Nachricht also Medien transportieren
nicht nur Botschaften sondern enthalten
in sich auch häufig selbstbotschaften
die aber nicht direkt sichtbar sind wir
müssen also Medien kritisch immer
unterwegs sein und auch das Medium auf
seine impliziten versteckten Botschaften
hin untersuchen sonst ist unsere
Kommunikation unvollständig und es ist
natürlich besonders wichtig in
wissenschaftlichen Kontexten wo ja
Objektivität angestrebt werden sollte
Kommunikation Medien erzeugen und
verändern auch räumliche Strukturen das
ist eine der wichtigen Gründe warum the
medium is the message weil Medien eine
besondere raumlogik
besitzen Raum und Kommunikationsform
hängen eng miteinander zusammen wir
haben das schon besprochen anhand der
Didaktik didaktische Strukturen sind in
der Regel räumliche Strukturen hier
geht's jetzt auch um
Kommunikationsformen didaktische Formen
sind auch immer Kommunikationsformen ähm
aber wir müssen darauf reflektieren dass
Raum immer auch die Kommunikation
verändert ganz zentral wird dieses Thema
jetzt mit Blick auf die neuen Medien
also vor allem das Internet digitale
Medien die verändern nämlich auch den
Kommunikationsraum durch virtuelle
Realitäten und virtuelle Räume z.B wenn
man ein Zoom Seminar veranstalt dann hat
man es hier mit einer wirtuellen
Räumlichkeit zu tun man begegnet sich
man interagiert auch wenn man nicht
physisch präsent es ist eine andere Form
von Präsenz eine virtuelle Form von
Präsenz und man kann sie jetzt natürlich
fragen wie virtuelle und physische Räume
interferieren auch dann wenn wir ein
zoomseminar starten leiten oder daran
teilnehmen befinden wir uns zugleich
immer in einem physischen Raum nämlich
zu Hause oder im Büro oder wo auch immer
und wir befinden uns zugleich in einem
virtuellen Raum also diese beiden Räume
schließen sich nicht aus ich kann nicht
sogleich im Büro sein und in der Küche
physische Räume schließen sich aus aber
wirtuelle Räume und physische Räume sind
miteinander kompatibel das ist also eine
ganz spannende Thematik wer sich mehr
dafür interessiert für diese Thematik
der virtuellen Realität da mache ich
oben rechts ein Link zu einer
Vorlesungsreihe von mir zum Thema
Philosophie der virtuellen Realität
hinein jetzt soll es aber weitergehen zu
den bestimmten Medien die wir hier
diskutieren wollen und wir wollen Sie
darfin befragen inwiefern sie sich
eignen für den wissenschaftstransfer für
die
Wissenschaftskommunikation jedes Medium
hat auch immer informationelle
Dimensionen es bestimmt die Art und
Weise was auch kommuniziert wird und es
kann darin äquat oder weniger adäquat
sein je nach Ziel was man sich eben
setzt und je nach Publikum dass man
adressieren möchte damit beginnen wir
mal ganz klassisch mit den Monografien
was ist eine Monografie eine Monografie
ein wissenschaftliches Werk das einem
einheitlich Thema gewidmet ist
Monografie kommt vom griechischen Monos
das heißt einzeln allein und grafet ist
die Schrift als eine einzelschrift
also ein ganz klarer thematischer Fokus
häufig sind es Bücher von einzelnen
Autorin Autoren wie z.B Dissertation
eine gute Dissertation muss einen klaren
thematischen Fokus haben sie darf nicht
zu weit das Thema wählen ein Überblick
geben über ganz verschiedene Dinge dann
ist sie keine Monographie mehr das sind
dann Sammelbände wir kommen darauf noch
genauer zu sprechen Vorteil ist ein
starker Fokus und eine Einschlägigkeit
also Monografien sind häufig die erste
Wahl wenn es um Forschungen geht die
sehr intensiv das Thema behandeln ein
Nachteil ist weil sie so speziell sind
weil sie so fokussiert sind sind sie in
der Regel nur für ein engeres
fachwissenschaftliches Publikum geeignet
Sammelbände sind jetzt gerade keine
Monographien oder zumindest häufig nicht
weil sie eher verschiedene Themen behand
sie haben zwar manchmal ein gemeinsames
Thema aber sind verschiedene
Perspektiven darauf und es werden auch
andere Themen angeschnitten heufig sind
das thematisch mehr oder weniger
zusammenhängende Einzelbeiträge ja
Sammelbände können besser sein wenn die
Beiträge aufeinander abgestimmt sind das
ist dann die Aufgabe der herausgebenden
aber häufig sind es eher lose Beiträge
die häufig auch gar nicht wirklich was
miteinander zusammenhängendes haben
deswegen muss man bei sammelbenden immer
ein bisschen kritisch sein oftmals sind
es mehrere herausgebende und Beitragende
hier stellt sich dann die Frage nach der
Koordination ein Vorteil es werden
verschiedene Perspektiven abgedeckt
thematisch aber auch aus Sicht der
autorinen Autoren jeder Autor hat ja
eine eigene
Forschungsperspektive das mag durchaus
auch im Sinne der Multiperspektivität
sinnvoll sein dabei darf aber nicht der
einheitliche Fokus aus dem Auge geradeen
sind oftmals deswegen nicht homogen und
auch nicht aus einem Guss dann vor
Nachteile haben Zeitschriften ist ein
weiteres wichtiges Publikationsorgan ein
wissenschaftliches Organ ich sag
deswegen Organ weil Zeitschriften mehr
sind als nur Medien Zeitschriften
besitzt in der Regel eine sehr komplexe
Struktur was herausgebende und
wissenschaftlicher Beirat anbelangt das
heißt sehr viele Personen aus dem
wissenschaftlichen Bereich verantworten
eine Zeitschrift und auch eine einzelne
Ausgabe der Zeitschrift häufig haben
diese Zeitschriften lang
Traditionen ideengeschichtliche
Traditionen sie existieren teilweise
schon seit mehreren Jahrzehnten
teilweise seit mehreren hundert Jahren
sie haben also gewisse Hintergründe die
es zu berücksichtigen gibt das hat den
Vorteil dass Zeitschriften häufig
einschlägig sind was bestimmte Tradition
Hintergründe Interessensgruppen
Leserpublikum Leserschaft anbelangt ein
Nachteil ist teilweise kann eine
Zeitschrift nur für ein kleines
Fachpublikum zugänglich sein gerade dann
wenn es sich z.B um eine sehr spezielle
Thematik handelt ich bringe ein Beispiel
von einer philosophischen Zeitschrift
das ist das philosophische Jahrbuch
ich war da lange Zeit Redakteur das ist
die älteste deutschsprachige
philosophische Zeitschrift die gibt seit
1888 relativ kontinuierlich bis zum
heutigen Tag und wer sich dafür
interessiert kann man auf die Homepage
gehen
www.philosophischesbjabo.de mach unten
in der Beschreibung auch den Link rein
und da kann man sich hier im Archiv alle
bislang bis 2009 erschienenen PDF
Dokumente ansehen und auch die Beiträge
durchsuchen nach bestimmten Begriffen
kann ich sehr empfehlen es gibt einen
wirklich wunderbaren Rückblick auf die
letzten Jahrzehnte und die philosophisch
geisteswissenschaftliche
geistesgeschichtliche Entwicklung wir
gehen weiter wir kommen zum Thema
Aufsätze und papers wie man es
neuerdings nennt papers so redet man
eher im angelsächsischen Bereich oder
auch im naturwissenschaftlichen Bereich
Aufsätze sagt man eher hier zu Lande im
deutschsprachigen Raum wenn man sie von
bloßen Beiträgen Z sammelbenden
verschieden möchte unterscheiden möchte
was ist der Unterschied zwischen
Aufsätzen bzw papers und Beiträgen der
Unterschied ist das Aufsätze wenn sie in
Zeitschriften erscheinen häufig anonym
begutachtet werden und zwar nach ganz
komplexen Verfahren von Seiten des
wissenschaftlichen Beirats deswegen ist
auch eine Zeitschrift ein
wissenschaftspublikationsorgan weil es
so komplex konstituiert ist man kann
verschiedene Formen der Begutachtung
unterscheiden blind blind double blind
Triple blind Triple blind bedeutet die
gutachtende Person weiß nicht von wem
der zu begutachtende Aufsatz ist und
auch eine andere Person die dann z.B in
Form der Redakteurin des Redakteurs die
Entscheidung mitteilt äh weiß auch nicht
wer die Person ist die den Aufsatz
eingereicht hatte weil alles durch
bestimmte Verfahren zumal digitale
Verfahren anonymisiert ist double plind
mein Gutachterin und Autor des Aufsatzes
wissen nichts voneinander das hat
natürlich große Vorteile ähm die
Anonymität ist gewahrt der Gutachter
kann unbefangen kritisieren oder auch
loben er weiß nicht von wem der Aufsatz
ist und die einreichende Person kann in
der Regel sicher sein auch wenn sie zehn
Mal eingereicht hat und jedes Mal wurde
der Aufsatz abgelehnt wird sie nicht in
eine schwarze Liste eingetragen und ihr
Renommee leidet nicht darunter ein
Vorteil ist auch Zeitschriften genießen
teilweise ein hohes renomme in der
Fachwelt gerade dann wenn sie
international erschein Englisch im
naturwissenschaftlichen Bereich ist das
üblich Stichwort science oder nature das
sind die topzeitschriften ein Aufsatz in
dieser Zeitschrift kann Karriere
bestimmen sein in den
Geisteswissenschaften ist die
Entwicklung noch nicht so weit gedienen
aber es gibt die Tendenz dass gerade in
angelsächsischen Zeitschriften auch ein
sehr geringe Annahmequote
existiert teilweise unter 5 % also nur
jeder 20 Aufsatz der eingereicht wird
kann nach diesem komplexen
Begutachtungsverfahren was häufig zwei
Gutachten erfordern angenommen werden
häufig muss man den Aufsatz noch mal
überarbeiten dann geht er wieder zurück
an die gutachtenden sowas kann teilweise
mehrere Jahre dauern bis der Aufsatz
angenommen wird oftmals sind dann die
Ergebnisse nur wenige ExpertInnen
Experten von Interessen weil es so
speziell ist äh und teilweise sind auch
die Aufsätze wenn man sie sich dann
kaufen möchte übers Internet oder als
Zeitschrift sehr sehr teuer die
akzeptanzquote ist eben sehr gering das
heißt man kann hier nicht alles was man
an ein Publikum vermitteln möchte
unmittelbar vermitteln gerade auch
deswegen weil es so lange dauert bis die
Ergebnisse erscheinen eine Ausnahme
machen hier early view also früher schon
Internet im Internet publizierte
Beiträge und auch Open Access also
öffentlich kostenlos zugängliche
Beiträge die dann dieses finanzielle
Problem lösen wir kommen noch auf Open
Access am Ende der vorgestellten Medien
Blogs ist auch ein wichtiges Thema hier
handelt es sich um aktuelle Beiträge
einzelner oder verschiedener
beitragender im neuen Medium des
Internets verschiedene Vorteile gehen
damit einher Aktualität es ist kostenlos
kostengünstig einfache Veröffentlichung
ohne den Umweg mittels Verlagen und
Zeitschriften man kann es direkt
veröffentlichen es erreicht Potenzial
größeres jüngeres Publikum gerade dann
wenn die Blogs auch abonniert werden und
eine weitere Vernetzung ist möglich über
die Option Teilen ich kann von
Blogseiten Teilen auf Facebook auf
Twitter oder jetzt Ex auf jedem Medium
dass ich möchte und ich kann sie auch
kommentieren das heißt es kann ja eine
Kontroverse stattfinden Foren sind
ähnlich verfasst wie
Blogs ein weiterer Nachteil ist jedoch
dass hoftmals keine Qualitätskontrolle
stattfindet als anders als bei
Zeitschriften gibt es hier häufig wenige
Menschen die für die Qualität
garantieren wenn es ein privater Blog
ist hängt von der Art des Blogs ab
öffentliche Blogs sind eher
qualitätssicher Stichwort Fake News
oftmals besteht keine
Langzeitarchivierung das heißt man kann
die Blogbeiträge 10 Jahre später
vielleicht nicht mehr zitieren weil der
Blog gar nicht mehr existiert und es
gibt keine gute
zitationsmöglichkeit wie ein Doi ein
Digital object identifier das ist eine
permanente Internetadresse über die ich
den internetinhalt auch immer fest und
genau zitieren kann ich gebe ein paar
Beispiele für Blogs hier haben wir den
Spektrum Blog Spektrum der Wissenschaft
einer der bedeutendsten
deutschsprachigen naturwissenschaftlich
Blogs hier sieht man es ist von Autorin
Autor die nicht anonym veröffentlichen
und man kann ja auch kommentieren das
also ein Vorteil das ein sehr seriöser
Blog gibt auch noch die Science Blogs
auch ein großer Blog auch hier sieht man
die Autorin den Autor und hier sind
sogar schon Kommentare darunter verfasst
worden hier sieht man wieder man kann es
Teilen Facebook und Twitter oder Ex das
ist der große Vorteil von Blogbeiträgen
sie können reibungsfrei im digitalen
Raum vernetzt werden man kann das auch
selbst betreiben und es auch in
didaktischer Hinsicht überlegen so wie
ich es z.B getan hatte mit einem Philo
Blog ein blogseminar philosophische
Theorien des Lebens auch hier kann man
in didaktischen Kontexten die
Studierenden anregen seminarbeiträge
Hausarbeiten in Form von Blogbeiträgen
zu verfassen auch hier besteht die
Möglichkeit das ganze zu
kommentieren Wikis sind ähnlich wie
Blogs ein Internetphänomen der neuen
Medien Wikis haben gegenüber Blogs den
Vorteil dass sie stärker thematisch
orientiert sind mehr begrifflich
orientiert sind hier gibt es natürlich
auch schon das Vorbild der
internetenzyklopädien die schließen an
an die große Tradition der
Enzyklopädie von dieer Ron dalomber da
mache ich auch oben rechts einen Link
rein zu diesem historischen Phänomen wer
sich dafür weiter interessiert es ist
sagen die Aktualisierung dieser
Tradition der Enzyklopädie zumeist
kostenlose sind auch selbstleicht
erstellbar und sie lassen sich auch
kollaborativ erarbeiten als
Gemeinschaftsprojekt und sie sind in der
Regel aktuell Nachteile teilweise
fehltende zitationsmöglichkeit und
Langzeitarchivierung teilweise auch
Unsicherheit bezüglich der Qualität wenn
es um kollaborative Artikel geht wie bei
Wikipedia so sieht Wikipedia aus die
freie Enzyklopädie man sieht hier recht
übersichtlich verschiedene Kategorien
und hier kann man auch immer die
Versionsgeschichte eines jeweiligen
Beitrag sich anschauen das hat vor und
Nachteile ich selbst habe auch mal ein
lehrprojekt gestartet zum Thema
wikiiseminar das war die Idee des
wikiprinzip auf didaktische Kontexte
anzuwenden hier kann man natürlich auch
wieder weiter dran arbeiten man kann
Studierende einladen ihre
seminarleistungen in Form von Blogs oder
Wikiartikel zu verfassen der Vorteil ist
natürlich auch dass solche Blogs im
Nachhinein noch zugänglich sind wenn man
eben auch die Internetseite PFT
Newsletter und Rundmail sind ein
traditionelles Verfahren was es
natürlich auch schon gab bevor es die
neuen Medien gab einfach Rundbriefe die
man abonnieren kannte das ist die
abonnentenbasis Vorteil es ist kostenlos
es ist aktuell man hat eine
Regelmäßigkeit idealerweise jede Woche
jeden Monat und man kann selbst
bestimmen ob man diese Rundbriefe
bekommen möchte oder abbestellen möchte
Nachteil sie sind sehr kurz häufig sie
bieten keineun keine tionmöglichkeit
häufig sind sie auch werbemäßig
interessiert social Media ist ein
weiterer großer Medienbereich wir haben
wir verschiedene Beispiele z.B Twitter
mittlerweile Ex Facebook Instagram was
es nicht alles gibt auch hier gibt's
viele Vorteile sie sind kostenlos man
kann Inhalte leicht teilen sie erreichen
prinzipiell ein großes Publikum und ein
neue Aspekt sie werden auch durch
Algorithmen durch algorithmische
Verfahren gerank und verknüpft sie
werden automatisiert und auf mögliche
nutzerinn und Nutzer ein mögliches
Publikum zugeschnitten das ist eine ganz
große Erleichterung was die Frage nach
dem Zielpublikum anbelangt der
Algorithmus regelt das selbst da muss
man selbst nicht mehr viel machen der
Nachteil ist es sind kommerzielle
Kontexte häufig twitter facebook die
machen ihr Geld ja mit unseren Daten
Stichwort Datenschutz wie seriös ist es
welche Daten möchte ich den Social Media
Plattform geben welche nicht ich werde
abhängig nicht von deren Infrastruktur
wenn der Kanal mal offline ist eine
technische Störung besteht dann bin ich
nicht mehr sichtbar und der Umfang ist
häufig auch begrenzt den ich
kommunizieren kann bei Twitter oder Ex
sind es nur eine bestimmte Zeichenzahl
genauso bei Facebook kann ich nicht
beliebig viel publizieren hier gibt's
ein Beispiel Donald Trump ist auf
Twitter oder Ex hier sieht man auch die
Möglichkeiten Kommentarfunktion
Teilfunktion Bewertungsfunktion und hier
Statistiken das ist auch ein wichtiger
Aspekt die digital Medien erlauben uns
häufig auch Statistiken zu erfassen was
auch für unsere Bewertung der Reichweite
der Kommunikation sehr sehr hilfreich
ist also datenmäßig haben hier riesen
Vorteile was auch statistische
Information anbelangt das sind natürlich
keine direkten Daten sonder sind
Metadaten aber auch Metadaten sind für
eine erfolgreiche Kommunikation und
Wissenschaftskommunikation entscheiden
die DFG die Deutsche
Forschungsgemeinschaft hat auch einen
eigenen Auftritt
auf Ex hier sieht man das das ist als
eine seriöse Organisation auch die sind
mittlerweile auch vormals Twitter aktiv
und hier z.B auch der österreichische
forschungsfond der Austrian Science Fund
auch der ist auf Twitter oder Ex präsent
youtube ist ein weiteres großes Phänomen
was mittlerweile sehr viele Menschen
rezipieren und zwar nicht nur rezipieren
sondern eben auch selbst aktiv als
Produzentin und Produzenten nutzen man
spricht hier vom prosument eine
Kombination aus Konsument und Produzent
das Motto war früher mal von Youtube
broadcast yourself
also betreibe deinen eigenen Kanal werde
dein eigener Regisseur Vorteil wieder
kostenlos Teilbarkeit im Netz großes
Publikum algorithmische
Vorverarbeitung viele Statistiken und
Effekte und häufig auch
interessenspezifisch man kann diese
Videos mit Tags also Kategorisierung
versehen und so eben auch viel genauer
ein mögliches Publikum anpassen Nachteil
auch hier es ist abhängig von einem
trittanbieter technologisch aber auch
datenmäßig und kommerziell ist es
interessiert hier müssen aufpassen
welche Information wir überhaupt ins
Internet stellen wollen ich gebe auch
hier ein Beispiel das ist mein eigener
Kanal filocast auf dem sich auch dieses
Video gerade findet der Kanal hat hier
sieht man über 6000 abonnentinen
Abonnenten über 600 Videos mittlerweile
und man sieht hier auch ein Logo das
heißt man kann i Kanäle sehr individuell
gestalten persönlich aber auch
institutionell
das ist sicherlich ein ganz ganz großer
Vorteil von Youtube hier habe ich mal
ein Video dieses Kanals was eines
unserer häufigsten gesehenen Videos ist
das ist ein Vortrag von Harald Lesch äh
den kann ich auch sehr empfehlen ich
mache oben rechts ein Link zu diesem
Video hinein und wenn man jetzt mal
schaut sieht man er hat schon 500 fast
600 likes bekommen wir gehen mal noch
ein bisschen genauer auf die Statistiken
ein ich gebe ihn da Einblick das erlaubt
nämlich auch Youtube ich kann schauen
wie alt sind die Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauer und hier sieht man es gibt
eine ganz klare Häufung im jüngeren der
jüngeren Hälfte also die drei5 bis
44-Jährigen sind am häufigsten vertrreet
mit knapp 30% aber knapp darunter auch
fortgeschrittene Studierende würde ich
mal sagen ja nach ihrem Studium die
Altersgruppe der 18 bis 24jährigen ist
sehr gering wie auch die Altersgruppe
über 65 also die im Berufsleben
stehenden sind hier sehr interessiert
daran man kann jetzt untersuchen ob das
bei anderen Kanälen oder anderen Videos
genauso ist
ich möchte noch eine Information geben
und zwar betrifft die die Geographie
auch das kann interessant sein wenn man
an ein Publikum kommunizieren möchte
hier sieht man natürlich es ist vor
allem ein deutschsprachiges oder
deutsches Publikum genauer was aus
Deutschland kommt Österreich ist auch
gut vertreten mit 5% fast die Schweiz
aber dann nimmt es schnell ab ne also
auch das kann sehr interessant sein wir
wollen noch einen Blick auf die
Durchschnittszeit werfen genauer
genommen den Median äh den Nutzerinnen
und Nutzer verbringen beim Ansehen von
Youtube Videos und man sieht hier
der Median ist bei un unter einer Minute
und 40 Sekunden ist eine sehr kurze
betrachtungsdauer das heißt Youtube
Videos leben davon dass sie in der Kürze
wichtige Inhalte kommunizieren weil
sonst die Teilnehmenden Anzahl sehr
schnell
abnimmt ja also hier muss man schnell
auf den Punkt kommen das ist sicherlich
eine interessante Information die man
auch nicht vernachlässigen darf weil das
Medium hier eben wieder auch den Erfolg
bestimmt podcasts sind auch auch ein
neueres Phänomen was eben Vorteile wie
kostenlose Zugänglichkeit Teilbarkeit
großes Publikum auch algorithmische
Verarbeitung alles das hat man hier auch
der Unterschied ist es ist rein
akustisch Podcasts in der Regel
Tondokumente Erzählungen einsprechungen
sind portabel die kann ich mitnehmen
weil sie auch eine geringe Größe haben
ich kann sie leicht abonnieren ist eine
Art akustischer Newsletter könnte man
sagen ein weiterer Punkt der vielleicht
jetzt eher ein Nachteil ist ist je nach
Plattform können Podcast kommerziell
sein man muss auf Datenschutz aufpassen
die gesprochene Sprache kann auch ein
Nachteil sein wenn man auch visuelle
Information haben möchte und podcastsind
der Regel nicht so gut zitierfähig weil
ich dann die Minute festhalten muss und
es nicht als schriftdokument vorlegen
habe häufig gibt es die Möglichkeit auch
Podcasts automatisch verschriftlichen zu
lassen mittels künstlicher Intelligenz
künstliche Intelligenz ist sowieso ein
Thema was ich hier jetzt nicht behandeln
kann weil hier momentan so viel
Entwicklung ist in Zukunft wir
künstliche Intelligenz was die
Kommunikation anbelangt noch eine viel
größere Rolle spielen zum Schluss möchte
ich noch auf Open Access eingehen das
ist ein anerkanntes
publikationsformat da können wir
kostenlos Artikel veröffentlichen und
Nutzerin Nutzer können idealerweise auch
kostenlos die Artikel sich dann ansehen
teilweise kostet es auch etwas dass wir
die Artikel dann bei Zeitschriften oder
Verlagen oder zw oder auch in Form von
Büchern zur freien Verfügbarkeit stellen
können weil der Verlag ja auch keine
Einnahmen dadurch hat wenn er kostenlos
in Inhalte zur Verfügung stellt das
heißt häufig muss man als Autorin
Autoren einen gewissen Betrag bezahlen
teilweise werden die auch übernommen von
Forschungsfonds je nach Zeitschrift kann
es eine sehr große Reichweite geben
denkt man mal an engelschsprachige
Verlage wenn man dort etwas Open Access
veröffentlicht ist es natürlich für ein
sehr großes Publikum attraktiv teilweise
es eben für die Autorin Autoren
kostenpflichtig das kann sehr schnell
mal in die Tausende von Euro gehen weil
der Verlag ja dadurch keine direkten
Einnahmen hat wenn interessentinen
Interessenten sich die Artikel kostenlos
herunterladen können so sieht das Logo
aus für Open Access dieses orangene
geöffnete Schloss ja das war ein kurzer
Einblick in die Frage nach gelingender
Wissenschaftskommunikation und ich hoffe
meine Diskussion der Medien
konnte die einzelnen Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauer auch weiter anregen vielen
Dank und bis zu einer nächsten Sitzung